>> Geraldo: WELCOME BACK TO
"THE FIVE."
SOCIALISM ISN'T THE ONLY THING
BERNIE SANDERS IS DEMANDING.
THE SENATOR HAS A LONG LIST OF
HOTEL DEMANDS THAT INCLUDE
PREFERRED SUITES WITH BATHTUBS,
KING-SIZE BED, ROOM BE KEPT AT
60 DEGREES, AND AN EXTRA BLANKET
THAT HAS TO BE DARK BLUE AND
MADE OF COTTON.
WE SHOULD HOOK HIM UP AT THE
MYPILLOW GUY.
SANDERS ALSO BECAME A HUGE FAN
OF PRIVATE PLANES DURING THE
CAMPAIGN AT LEAST AFTER GETTING
OVER THE "LITTLE EMBARRASSED
PULLING INTO THE TERMINAL
THING."
YOU DON'T WANT TO AVOID HORRIBLE
COMMERCIAL AIRPORTS.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE HIM A BAD
PERSON.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHY I LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS.
AS YOU KNOW, EVERYONE HERE ON
"THE FIVE" KNOWS I'M AN EXPERT
IN DIVA BEHAVIOR.
A THERMOSTAT AT 60 IS NOT DIVA
BEHAVIOR.
IT'S NECESSARY WHEN YOU NEED TO
SLEEP.
IT'S ALSO LIKE, YOU ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE COZY WHEN YOU ARE
WORKING.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO BE COLD
BECAUSE IT KEEPS YOU AWAKE.
ALSO, I MEAN LIKE, LOOK, HE'S
GOT TO GET SOMEWHERE.
HE CAN USE A PRIVATE PLANE.
IT'S EASIER DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
MY PROBLEM IS THAT AS A
SOCIALIST WHO HAS NEVER ACTUALLY
LIVED IN A SOCIALIST PARADISE,
PERHAPS HE SHOULD STAY IN REALLY
BAD HOTELS.
BECAUSE EVEN THE WORST HOTEL IN
AMERICA ARE BETTER THAN THE ONES
IN CUBA.
BUT HE SHOULD AT LEAST GET A
TASTE OF IT.
>> Geraldo: DR. SAPHIER, FIRST
OF ALL I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR GUIDANCE DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
YOUR GUIDANCE AND EXPERTISE
REALLY HELPED CALM THE WATERS,
FOCUS ON WHAT IT TAKES.
BERNIE SANDERS IS 79 YEARS OLD,
YEAR WERE LIVING AND I AM.
AT WHAT POINT DO WE SENIORS
TYPICALLY NEED EXTRA ATTENTION?
>> Dr. Nicole: [LAUGHS]
WHILE I WAS RESEARCHING FOR THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S VERY SERIOUS.
I HAVE TO ADMIT, THE 60 DEGREES
AND A KING-SIZE BED, THAT SOUNDS
QUITE LOVELY TO ME.
BUT I REALLY WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THE BLUE BLANKET IS ALL ABOUT.
WHY BLUE?
HE HAS GRAY HAIR.
YOU CAN DEFINITELY SEE THE GRAY
ON IT.
THAT IS THE ONLY QUESTION.
DID YOU KNOW KANYE WEST, ALL HE
LIKES?
HE JUST WANTS LIP BALM, SHOWER
SHOES, AND A LOT OF ALCOHOL.
THAT SEEMS REASONABLE.
>> Geraldo: I WANT SPACED HERE
LOTS OF SPACE.
DANA, DOESN'T EVERYONE WANT LOTS
OF SPACE?
>> Dana: IF YOU EVER HAVE A
CHANCE TO FLY ON UP PRIVATE
PLANE, YOU DO NOT EVER WANT TO
GO BACK.
GOING THROUGH TSA AND TAKING
YOUR SHOES OFF.
THE BLANKET THING REMINDED ME OF
LINUS.
THAT'S THE FIRST THING I THOUGHT
OF.
THE OTHER THING I WAS THINKING
IS WHY IS IT AOC OUT THERE
OUTRAGED?
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ARE WASTED KEEPING
A ROOM AT 60 DEGREES AT ALL
TIMES?
THAT IS THE SCANDAL HERE.
WE MUST FOLLOW UP ON IT
TOMORROW.
>> Geraldo: JESSIE, DO YOU
REMEMBER YOUR FIRST TIME?
STAY FOR MY FIRST TIME WHAT,
GERALDO GOES TO IT ALL ONCE
TOGETHER.
EVERYONE TAKE YOUR PICK.
BEFORE I UNDERSTAND THE BLUE
BLANKET.
THAT IS A POWER MOVE.
MOST BLANKETS ARE WHITE OR CREAM
COLORED.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY MAKING THE
HOTEL MANAGER GO OUT AND ACQUIRE
A BLUE BLANKET.
BUT THE REST OF IT IS TOO BASIC.
WHAT IS BERNIE GOING TO ASK FOR
A LATE CHECK OUT?
[LAUGHTER]
HE REQUIRES A BATH.
BERNIE IS TAKING A BATH AT A
HOTEL IN IOWA OR NEW HAMPSHIRE?
OH, MY GOD, THE IMAGE.
THE PRIVATE JET REQUEST WAS
FUNNY THOUGH.
BERNIE REQUESTS A PRIVATE JET
THAT'S NOT TOO BUMPY.
THAT IS CALLED TURBULENCE.
THE PILOT HAS TO JUST FIND
SMOOTHER IT HERE.
THERE IS NOT A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A BUMPY JET AND A
NONBUMPY JET.
IT'S CUTE, YOU KNOW?
>> Greg: I THINK HE IS
ADORABLE.
>> Dr. Nicole: HE WAS
CHARTERING PLANES.
WHERE IS AOC?
TH